il y a 13 ans je suis Alizée
accueilli à bras ouverts dans une
famille aimante de mon petit légal
innocent je suis devenu un espoir pour
mes parents qui nous laissait de grands
projets pour moi jouer
au fil des années
j'ai commencé à explorer mon
environnement
Anna a joué et découvrir le monde qui
m'entourait grandir ensuite j'ai
commencé à grandir
additionner les choses qui se passaient
autour de moi
parler puis je commençais à balbutier à
dire tout et rien parler sans dire
quelque chose d'important apprendre et
penser ainsi j'ai appris à penser par
moi-même écrire enfin je me sentais
prête à découvrir le monde extérieur
grâce à la clairvoyance de mes parents
je suis allée à l'école où j'ai appris
Ali et écrire bref étudier rêver comme
chaque enfant j'ai des aspirations des
rêves de vie pleinement mon enfance et
de bénéficier de toutes les opportunités
pour avoir une vie meilleure créer je
voudrais mettre mon potentiel en avant
pour créer l'avenir inspirer et changer
le monde et inspirer de nombreux enfants
à comprendre à quel point ils sont dotés
de capacité in
pour accomplir de merveilles et
participer à la promotion et à la
protection de leurs droits et enfin le
plus important contribuer à changer le
monde
ne m'en voulez pas si je suis encore
dans ma vie
je rêve dans mon meilleur pour chaque
enfant
c'est une aspiration
une idéal dont je rêve
je ne pense pas être la seule
les parents les éducateurs les
institutions l'état bref j'imagine
une belle question qui milite encore
d'être posée mais quels sont les actions
mises en place pour répondre à cette
idéal et contribuer à réaliser
pleinement ce rêve afin qu'il devienne
une réalité dans un monde en pleine
ascension
tout ceci repose sur le respect de nos
droits nous les enfants c'est la base de
tout pour avoir un mode meilleur où
chaque enfant est heureux et épanoui
Mesdames et Messieurs chers invités
bonjour je réponds au nom de Diallo
Mariama et les vancas de 9e année au
complet scolaire je suis la présidente
du Parlement des Enfants de Guinée et
même du club Rabbi et les enfants
il y a tout juste une semaine le monde
entier a célébré la journée
internationale des droits des enfants
33 ans c'est l'âge de la Convention
relative au droit des enfants pour moi
cela signifie beaucoup d'années
beaucoup de femmes nage d'ailleurs
mais 33 ans de le parcours de cette
belle convention surtout beaucoup
d'histoires à raconter et encore
beaucoup de défis à relever pour le
bien-être chaque enfant
c'est quoi la Convention relative au
droit des enfants c'est le premier
document international le plus ratifié
en matière de droit de l'homme il
définit une liste de droits de l'enfant
comprenant le droit à la vie à la santé
a éducation et le droit de jouer ainsi
que le droit à une vie de famille à être
protégé de la violence et de la
discrimination et faire entendre sa voix
après toutes ces années je me pose
encore la question pourquoi pourquoi les
droits des enfants sont encore bafoués
pourtant elle n'a pas choisi d'être
albinos
il est obligé de vendre pour aider sa
famille et au moment où je vous parle
Blandine 8 ans a été kidnappé il a été
retrouvé morte
au droit des enfants
aujourd'hui nous sommes censés être à
l'abbit de ces violences brimath et de
vivre pleinement en France et grandit
dans un monde meilleur mais où se trouve
le blocage c'est à plusieurs niveaux
en plus de la violation de nos droits
nous avons la précarité de nos
conditions de vie
l'accès manquant à l'éducation scolaire
de qualité la poursuite du bonheur
l'aspiration d'être valorisée en tant
qu'enfant jeune dette respectée protéger
et de jouir pleinement de tous nos
doigts
mais l'espoir est endermie aujourd'hui
grâce à des organisations comme le club
Rabhi et les enfants le Parlement des
Enfants de kiné l'UNICEF plan
international Guinée nous les enfants
nous sommes confiants à l'avenir car
nous sommes valorisés
tous les enfants nus dans ce beau pays
que ma chère Guinée
avoir l'opportunité de développer leur
potentiel et de le valoriser
je me tiens devant vous aujourd'hui pour
lancer un cri de cœur sur le manque
d'écoute
de nos opinions
car j'en ai à revendre Maria Montessori
le disait fermement je cite libérer le
potentiel de l'enfant il vous
transformerait le monde avec lui fin de
citation non nous y croyons et vous
non
[Applaudissements]
nous enfin voulons être de combat
nous faire entendre
et clamer notre droit à être impliqué
dans les actions menées à notre nom
aujourd'hui nous avons décidé de devenir
les acteurs de notre avenir et
participer au développement de nos
communautés
je suis cet enfant qui vous demande à
vous de m'associer me guider pour que
demain je puisse devenir responsable de
mon avenir et acteurs du développement
de ma communauté je décide d'agir pour
un avenir meilleur bref je décide d'être
la relève et ouvrir la voix pour les
futures générations Mesdames et
Messieurs chers invités évitons des
spectateurs du changement
soyons des acteurs de changement je vous
remercie